hi everyone my name is camera shavers
and I'm Tony Miller and this is Tamra
Jessa and Cody also just saw two as well
officially bad and eight bad eh oh you
guys we just saw our own summarizes the
print plan overview now remember you can
really remember the opening where they
highlighted the words so you can
remember because they won't because that
the right up top they're like we don't
think you're smart enough to pick up on
sequel so yeah it was a it was rise then
dawn than war mm-hmm anymore
hi was thinking about this with Jim
actually where he was saying that the
two movies before this of the new reboot
were very much like a it looks okay and
then you go see it it's like you know
what that was actually pretty damn good
and I feel similarly with this I think I
wasn't you know particularly looking
forward to and I wasn't not but I wasn't
soaked about it and it was pretty damn
good
I'm a fan of the point of the Age
franchise until the dill to this wasn't
I
I've seen all the plenty of the H movies
before 2011
so I didn't watch the first of this one
I didn't watch the second of this one I
haven't seen any of the original and I
will probably end up doing like the very
first one for Tamara's never seen
tonight I should I should do all like
just for fun you and I should just watch
every single one they get real weird I
don't want to engage her son anymore you
watch too many perspectives the
franchise at a certain point gets so
weird and like heavy-handed politically
like yeah yeah I saw the first one of
the new and I didn't see the second but
I know that they're kind of their own
things each of them they have like
participation the same same overall like
thing has happened and like what has
caused the Apes to have a higher
learning and intelligence a higher
learning the higher learning oh man
those higher learning tell you this much
we're not a hard one to take
this one we were saying is if you
haven't seen the first two of this newer
trilogy that really easy to pick up on
yeah I mean I read the plot summaries on
Wikipedia for the first two and so I
knew enough for like I was watching and
I was like they do a pretty decent job
of not heavy handedly kind of catching
you up anyway I didn't see the first one
of the reboot because as you'll remember
from the alien or was it up prometheus
but the other one
thank you covenant review James Franco
was in it and so I was nowhere near it
and then call me Oh James and then Dave
spine no send Dave over have you seen
the room the escape artist
no I've seen the pretty dear I haven't I
haven't seen the room though
oh really I didn't see the second of the
reboot plenty of movies because I
literally did not know it came out it
came and went in theaters that I had no
concept of an existing until this
wouldn't came out and I was like oh they
finally made another one people like
know therefore in 2014 my little boy
mm-hmm this movie was really smooth and
touching and I don't know what I was
expecting I was kind of expecting to to
feel a bit more for the humans that go
home they can go joon-ha quick a lot of
the businesses yeah I I mean it was such
a good story about these Apes there's
only one point in the movie that kind of
hooked me out of it that I was kind of
like I don't really want to see that
with my Apes here and that was when they
were doing like Roman Roman odd um but
because it wasn't like sexual romance it
was like hug like kissy like romantic
roles like it was a little off-putting
but other than that um I thought they
were a beautiful soul and really sweet
and I got teary I see it
like the overall story was beautiful
they did a really good job of nuance
which was not which is what I was not
expecting I was expecting like a weird
action
movie saying like I don't really know I
was expecting something more like a
Transformers II type thing and this was
like what if someone was in charge of
transformers that had a concept of story
like it had really good action not like
there was time from like I was like
clutching like my chest I'm like
surprised oh god no yeah I mean like for
not really even knowing these characters
other than having read the last two
movies I hooked in real quick as a plate
of the 8th fan I like that there was I
guess because it's also early in the
civilization of the Age there was more
nuance in the different eight types
because like in the especially like the
plan especially like the plan of the
Apes Tim Burton one but also in the
older ones there's so divided where it's
like no gorillas are like this and
chimpanzees are like this and
orangutangs are like this and in this
one they definitely had their strengths
and weaknesses but the like but the
gorilla was so caring the orangutan was
still strong like they weren't just they
weren't just like weird stereotypes of
what there's about what station they're
supposed to hold in the government of
eight yeah I didn't know that about the
original yeah that but yeah that's so
true I really didn't like their specific
jobs but they were able to do everything
else with jarran orangutan still went
with them on their main like crazy
mission so it's really nice so it's
really nice so it's really nice
so that was one and I'm glad that
Wendy's here for this because she needs
to know but that was one of my two
problems with the movies actually so one
of my problems with the movie was that
there was like a really sudden tonal
shift at one point where it's like
really dramatic like essentially like
slavery revolt type scene like a real
Amistad moment and then it's been like
right like less than a minute after that
is like a joke and it's my character
that I love I fell in love with that
character in a weird way but like it was
just kind of like ah we should have
maybe let that breathe a bit before we
do a joke suddenly oh yeah I know I love
that they brought in this unlikely
source of comedy it was great it was
really hoping Oh weird a choice it
ultimately totally worked I think I
don't remember the point you're talking
about
retain things but I was the binoculars
oh that was less than a minute after
they like that like there was less than
a minute after a major confrontation
where someone is like shot dead in front
of everybody and then they like they are
begging for food and water and out of
fear they continue to do slave labor and
then less than a minute later there's a
binoculars gag and it's just kind of
like okay well I'm not ready to laugh
right now I still I still feel really
emotional about that moment I don't know
maybe I'm too picky about my own success
with our movie do you think my other
problem is when Cesar goes off on his
vendetta crusade and getting like if the
posse joins in they did literally what
you're not supposed to do which is every
department head and like and like chief
of like like on the cabinet rode off
with the president and vice president
into danger unless no one in charge and
no one sensibly to take over it they all
were murdered and it it alleged their
demise for sure they shouldn't done that
but yeah also those were the established
characters of the movie so far so
villains gonna go right I know first
right I mean like it made sense it made
sense as a movie thing but it didn't
make sense as a world thing actually you
know what I would have been a really
great opportunity to give Lake more than
just being to go the girlfriend of the
dead son right right or something I
really liked about it was that they
added in the element of the sickness
this is totally getting into spoilers
they added the element of the sickness
that the humans are getting this virus
to and they're unable to speak and it's
I guess like their blood contact um
because there was a blood on the doll
and he got it through that do you think
is that huh yeah I think yeah I think
it's like something at that or just like
the contact yeah I've been quite cool
motivation for him
his name means main bad guy oh I think I
don't remember it's called the colonel
right yeah what are you really yes thank
you oh the actor you're asking for the
character's name no yeah what do you
hear Wilson I don't know you um Kirk
Douglas Jeff Bridges I like the added
motivation that gave him with his son
and all of that background he was the
worst benefit it's a great role for
Woody Harrelson because anytime you get
to any time woody relson just be
freaking crazy when ya to be bonkers
that's always a good Woody Harrelson
troll oh you're so right yeah yeah yeah
overall I thought I was really good
yes um I get six and a half maybe
drivers out of 22 bought babies I'm
going to give it a five out of five
knowing look from an orangutan ha ha ha
ha
that was my favorite character Maurice
he just was always always so many going
he is so many knowing looks yeah you're
the one one why doesn't anything I would
recommend seeing it especially if you
benefit of the others yeah I'm gonna go
watch the others it's a disappointment
yes but later do an end for the rest of
my life
ha ha ha ha Donna Lou next week I'm
pretty sure doing the emoji movie huh
I'm gonna smile my face is going to be
just one emoji the whole time I'll tell
you that much I actually want these like
hoping for it to just be like amazing so
we have Larry we have been surprised
yeah so we will see and we will see you
all next week
remember Apes are stronger together bye
[Music]